okay okay so my name is Karen Eden and I
have dr. Heidi Nelson joining mean the
two of us are going to present mammal
screen today and so we're gonna hand the
mic off a few times so that that's
planned so what we're going to be
presenting is a tool that helps patients
and clinicians know which patients are
above average risk for breast cancer and
also provides a decision aid so they can
decide how often to be screened and when
to start screening all those kinds of
details okay all right and the summer
interns for this or I oh and go Cole
raise your hands so these are the two
summer interns I'll talk a little bit
about their projects here in just a few
minutes okay so the current screening
recommendations for average-risk women
are to initiate mammography no earlier
than age 40 and no later than age 50 and
one of the key points in there is for
average-risk okay but how do you know if
your average risk this tool helps you
know that it occurs at least by annually
as frequently as annually continues
until age 74 and but age alone should
not be the basis for stopping screening
and decisions regarding when to initiate
screening and how often to screen and
when to stop screening should be based
on periodic shared decision-making which
we're going to learn about a little bit
today involving the woman and her
healthcare provider all right so first
of all you might be wondering what is
shared decision-making shared
decision-making is an approach so that
women the woman and her provider her
clinician in her position can have
conversation to understand the risks and
benefits of screening and they can
assess what's really important to the
women in making this decision and but it
should consider things like the
patient's own breast cancer risk what
her life expectancy is what commit core
morbidities and I threw this this Venn
diagram up here because you know we have
medical evidence we have patient
preferences we have clinical
circumstances and all of this has to be
brought into that whole conversation so
you can't just read a paper and decide
hey that paper says I shouldn't be
screened done it's it's a much more
complex decision than that all right so
this tool that we have created Heidi and
I is a risk tool to identify above
average risk and average with patients
based on major risk factors in family
history and she's going to speak a
little bit about those risk factors and
why those are really important to
identify women who are average risks go
on to use this tool called a decision
aid to help them decide when to begin
screening and how often to go there's
educational material there's a priority
setting activity and then there's a
customized report that the woman and her
clinician can use to in a shared way
decide what's the best strategy for her
all right so this tool is called mammal
screen and you can actually go in and
try it we actually just finished
implementing this with three OHSU
clinical practices in general internal
medicine and the women in that clinic
who were age appropriate and didn't have
a history of breast or ovarian cancer
were given eight were sent on my chart
message encouraging them to use this new
tool that we had created and then we
collected data on feasibility uptake and
clinton and clinical outcomes all right
so now let's begin to talk about those
risk factors that are very important to
us to make to indicate whether a
person's average or above-average hi
first off let me just see it do have
anybody in the room who's a clinician at
this point we're quite a few people well
you probably know that there are
actually very few things in medicine
that are clear-cut we all try to boil it
down and make it really clear-cut there
are very few things that it's actually
really clear what you're supposed to do
or advise to patients patients don't
always fit the studies that we've we've
read the things we've been taught every
case is a little uniquely different some
are a lot different and in the field of
prevention and screening this is
especially important because actually
harms are more important to consider
than benefits because you don't want to
take a healthy person off the street and
in the name of prevention you don't want
to hurt them do something that actually
good for them and so that's why weighing
benefits and harms is so important in
prevention particularly if you had end
stage cancer or a serious illness you
might take a few more risks for beforeit
treatment because the alternative
doesn't look so great in prevention the
alternative is well I just go back to my
life and don't get screened and there
could be a bad outcome there but it's
it's it's not in your face kind of like
with treatment so it's very different so
that's what we emphasize benefits and
harms and that's why a big reason why
shared decision-making is even probably
more important in these fuzzy areas and
in the longer version of this talk I
said we spend quite a bit of time going
through those fuzzy areas and why
they're fuzzy but the fact that we are
aren't real clear or accurate about how
to identify a high-risk person is
because all the risk calculators that
have been invented don't really work
they were developed from population data
and they don't work on individual
individual women they don't they're poor
predictors of an individual risk so any
kind of calculator the famous of Gale
model is almost as just barely better
than a coin toss when you're talking to
an individual patient so as you saw from
the breast cancer screening guidelines
that were shown there the edges are
really fuzzy I spent years going through
all that data and we really don't see
none of the trials show benefit for
women in their 40s to screen they just
don't a mortality benefit but there are
women in that group who should be
screened because they're not your
population average person so what we
wanted to do with mamuh screen is to
help clinicians and patients at least
triage or sort them out in a way that
doesn't
falsely imply accuracy like a gale model
that gives you a very precise estimate
that really doesn't even make sense what
we try to do to determine risk is to get
what we call the flags kind of high-risk
flags anybody who has any of these
things that we start off mammoth screen
with is raising a flag for clinical
action it's much more practical and we
thought more useful to clinicians and
patients so the high risk flags or
anybody who has a symptom
so we we actually didn't even have this
and it really versions because we
thought well for screening people you
know don't have symptoms but we found
out that a lot of people and women as we
were screening them or asking them about
getting into the study they actually had
lumps or something there introduced
something they were concerned about so
the very first question is are you
having any symptoms now breast skin
changes lumps bumps kind of a list of
things and in reality most those turn
out to be benign but you really don't go
into a decision process unless you can
kind of evaluate the current symptoms so
that's kind of the first question you
having symptoms if you do they're
directed to to go see their clinician
and work that up is it a big deal or not
sometimes it is most time it's not but
it's good to get that out of the way
first then there are it's a short list
of very important risk factors that put
you in a high risk surveillance group
there's no need for you to go deeper
into this tool than that so right off we
asked some these stories one of them is
having had high-level radiation from age
10 to 30 somebody was treated with
Hodgkin's lymphoma
for instance not just somebody getting a
lot of chest x-rays that's very unusual
but there are people out there
especially in a academic Medical Center
who may have had high level radiation
exposure during those ages and they
should just go on to a special pathway
of their own we also know there are
pathogenic mutations of certain genes
that increase your risk for breast
cancer quite high our levels sometimes
people have family members with those
and they don't really know what their
status is sometimes they know their
status and they're followed very
differently those are the brca1 and 2
genes so anyone with a pathogenic
mutation or a family with pathogenic
mutations needs to go to the genetic
counseling clinic and work that up
rather than go to the mammoth screening
tool and of course there are a lot of
survivors of breast cancer a few
survivors of ovarian cancer but a lot of
survivors of breast cancer or even early
very early stages especially go on for
many many years in primary care clinics
and they're actually managed a little
differently in follow-up screening so
there they're just kind of flying under
the radar in primary care so we need to
identify who they are and figure out
what would there be their surveillance
pattern so these are kind of the big
flags at the beginning why go to some
calculator that doesn't really give you
a meaningful number when there's
actually some big stuff at the front end
so they get used to new those they have
a clinically actionable red flag and
then we have them leave the tool and go
on to follow up so the next part we also
work through another area that may or
may not be an important risk factor is
if they've had a previous breast biopsy
you know sadly a lot of people who have
biopsies and don't really know what the
answer to the biopsy was except maybe it
wasn't cancer but there are many
intermediate high res lesions that just
sort of fall off of people's memories
because they have you know fancy names
and maybe it wasn't really explained
that there are there a high risk lesion
or not most of those biopsies are benign
but people often don't know so if
they've had any any biopsies that were
high resolutions or certainly cancer
they get a message and follow up with
their clinic if they aren't sure they
also there's some follow-up as to let's
figure out what that is
if it's important or not then a separate
study we actually looked at how well
pathologists agree on these biopsies and
sadly for those high resolutions there's
only a 50% concordance so that's a I
wish you watch the area as well so that
that needs a little more rigor
patients need to know the uncertainty of
that particular diagnosis so those
people get moved through the system and
may or may not go into mammoth screen
then we go looking at their family
history of genetic risks for cancer and
this adapts a CDC developed tool it's a
triage tool it's not telling you that
you need to go get your genes tested at
this point but it will triage you to a
suspicious risk group that would go to
that may be a genetic counselor where
they spend at least an hour with you and
pull up all kinds of beaut wonderful
kindred software and spend a lot of time
with you actually sorting this out so
this is a triage tool to get people to
genetic counseling if they need to or
not so the next where do we are oh so
here we also this is how it fits in
those questions are part of this
part of this is being Ashkenazi Jewish
ancestry increases your risk for some of
those pathogenic mutations it's not
there on a majority of people it's a
small proportion of Ashkenazi Jewish
individuals but it's there we need to
know that family history if they go
through the questions they get through
all of this then they go to the decision
age okay so now the people who move on
to use the decision aid they are women
who are average risk and we develop this
decision aid through meeting with
physicians and clinicians and with
patients because what we wanted to write
this in a way that it was it was very
understandable so this first screen the
first picture that you look at actually
went through quite a bit of change and
in fact Lindsay who helped us with this
early on who's joined us today can speak
to all the different ways that this this
this graphic changed the initial graphic
was one individual woman and we actually
had a very aggressive cancer on one side
of her body and a less aggressive on the
other side everybody quickly understood
the tortoise and the hare they
understood the side of the lesions but
what we didn't recognize until we were
interviewing patients is that they
misunderstood that they thought oh one
side of my if I if the cancers on the
left side of the body it's gonna be more
aggressive and that was not what we
meant so we went back to our graphic
artist and we said we need to change
this because it was it was conveying a
message we hadn't intended so we do a
lot of work to make sure that things are
written in a way that's understandable
and that convey a message that we
intended okay this figure too went
through a lot of changes you probably
have seen pictographs where they might
show a thousand dots some of them are
colored in certain ways well people have
a hard time with a denominator of a
thousand that's that's very hard to
understand so this this particular flow
chart tested very well and we have to
actually do a quite a bit of work just
even in the plain language here
initially when we had this this design
we did not have the words is missed so
you see we have a thousand women
average-risk have a mammogram in their
40s today 125 are going to get that
dreaded phone call we see something with
to have some more imaging 875 are going
to be told that they have normal results
however one cancer is missed originally
we just said one cancer and when we
interviewed patients about those two
forms they the woman said well I'm
really worried about this because it's
missed but it was actually missed in the
other diagram as well we just didn't
have the words is missed so that's what
that's the kind of testing you have to
do with products so that patients really
understand what you mean but now let's
follow this path for the hundred and
twenty five who get that phone call say
we need to do more testing 121 do not
have cancer two cancers would be found
and two pre-cancers would be found all
right so now as you may recall when I
first introduced this new study that we
were doing we wanted to look at uptake
we wanted to know how many patients and
would actually use the tool if they're
invited to use it so what we found is if
you send a MyChart message inviting a
patient from their clinician that
clinicians name was actually in the
message so about 76 percent will open
the message and we sent three messages
the first message and then two reminders
so they had they had a few opportunities
to open this message but they still had
to click on the link to get to Mammal
screen so we have 339 out of the 448 we
invited who actually opened the
invitation 214 clicked on the link but
did not go forward and we have some
ideas about why they might not have gone
forward at the time we had to upload a
very long consent form before they could
get to the decision aid and I think that
proved to be a barrier
fortunately the IRB has recognized that
and has a new way to approach that
consent process so we won't have to
upload a very long consent form before
they get to the decision aid but 125 of
those 339 consented and went on and for
n of those almost everybody completed so
once they got into the tool they liked
it and it didn't take a huge amount of
time you're gonna see in the next slide
oh that's just characteristics about who
who responded but you can see that time
to take to complete the risk algorithm
we're talking about three or four
minutes
we're not talking about a 30-minute
experience so it took him three or four
minutes if they were average risk they
went on to use the decision aid again
that was like a three minute experience
that was not a lengthy experience so
this is a tool that could be done as
you're sitting and waiting in the
waiting for your appointment so it's not
it's not a big time invasive experience
now what we found we also interviewed
eight patients who participated they
reported that it was highly intuitive it
was easy to navigate through we did lots
of testing on navigation so we were glad
to hear that but it didn't necessarily
change their screening attention and
what we did learn is that a number of
these women are already screening but
where this tool I think will be
particularly interesting is when we
reach that audience that's deciding
about screening seven of the eight
patients would recommend manless screen
to other women who might be less
knowledgeable on on the benefits and
harms of screening and need to decide
about getting a mammogram so at the same
time for those 118 people who completed
we went in and looked at their medical
charts we wanted to see if the medical
charts also identified whether someone
was above average risk and where that
information was in the chart so we had
two medical students who helped us with
that and what we found is that a large
amount of the risk information was
unstructured meaning it was listed maybe
in family history but maybe not in the
cell it might have been listed in a
progress note oh patient mentioned that
grandma so-and-so was diagnosed with
breast cancer but it wasn't formally put
into any kind of algorithm like mammal
screens so that information might be
there might not be there okay so what we
found is between the two approaches one
approach was using mammal screen the
other approach was was mining the chart
21 women were identified as above
average risk out of that 118 but there
was not agreement only in the case of
seven did both my mammal screen and the
chart using the same algorithm both ways
identified women who were above average
risk so in order to get complete
information on the patient you really
need to have
and that's what we're gonna move into
what the summer interns are helping with
the summer we did interviews also with
our three physicians and one mA they had
a positive experience they felt the
patients were empowered and more
informed they would like to link it with
it with a planned visit which you know I
think would be very possible they also
wanted to have more flexibility on
notifications so for example one of our
clinicians who was also a
co-investigator on the project she
wanted to get to know what every one of
her patients use the tool whether their
average risk or not but the others
really wanted a priority they wanted to
be notified if someone has symptoms
clearly but also the average risk the
above average risk women who weren't
being screened and so they didn't want
their boxes filling up with all these
reports so so that made sense to us okay
so now we get on to it aisle and go
Kohler doing this tool is right now in
English but we know that when we roll it
out for example to quality and some of
the other locations having the tool in
Spanish will be really important so I
was helping us with that he's already
sent a translation version to our
programmer who will be uploading it to
the website so that we'll be able to
test a Spanish version and then go Cole
is helping us with integrating Mammal
screen better with epic so let me put up
this like ugly scary-looking diagram
it's not that bad
and so so at the beginning we have epic
and in there there's information about
the patient and there's history and so
from epic using my chart are you all
familiar with my chart I see lots of
people nodding yay
there's the messages sent to the patient
inviting them to use Mammal screen they
use Mammal screen there's a report
that's generated they go through the
risk algorithm but we somehow have to
get that information back over here to
epic and right now it's very manual
meaning the research coordinator and the
MA had to upload the report and do a lot
of the the routing and triaging and
messaging but ideally this would be done
more invisibly so Kokkola is helping us
with beginning that using a tool called
smart on fire so
that platform is where he's beginning to
learn about that platform so are we and
how we may be able to move forward with
that okay so I just want to acknowledge
our funding from the knight Cancer
Support Grant and from NLM for
supporting the interns on this project
and questions for heidi and i were able
to compare that to patients that
normally would just get an invitation
from their provider to get a mammogram
to see if it increased the number of
mammograms that the patient's not yet
that is something we want to look at in
the future I think we want to look at to
see are the more above average patients
getting in there getting screen right
we're wanting to take the path the pilot
data that we we got and create a bigger
project with clinical outcomes because
that's really where it matters what our
patients doing it doesn't matter in
their health care so that would be the
next big step and hopefully look at
funding for that hopefully we can use
the Spanish version and have you know
we're the first population
it's obviously tons of work you guys
have already done it's really amazing to
see this thank you I'm how do you
envision this tool fitting into the
clinic workflow you mentioned that that
you notice it doesn't take very much
time to to complete but you know there
it might be competing with other forms
or in the future other apps or what have
you and then also the portal and my
chart update can be a barrier and then
and but but you've also gotten feedback
from providers and in terms of how it
might integrate in the work so what how
do you think this is going to is it
going to be all of the above
just as long as it gets done you know
that you do it at any time but what do
you what are you seeing going forward
you're asking a really good question and
that's where we will in future work
we're going to be needing to have
conversation with patients and with with
the physicians participating because
what we did learn is not brief all of
our physicians they had very different
needs in terms of when they wanted to be
notified they didn't want the some of
them didn't want their boxes filled you
know with average-risk patients that
maybe don't need anything right away but
they did want to know about the patients
who had symptoms or above average was
and we're not screening so I think
they'll be definitely a qualitative
piece to what you're asking I think we
learned a bit from the pilot but I don't
know that we've got an absolute model
for everybody yeah I mean ideally what
we're doing is sorting through a lot of
murk to get actionable things which
should save everybody time currently
it's it's sort of glacially happening if
at all and what we found a lot of the
women with symptoms or there are a lot
of people with pretty significant family
history zoom a need to go through
genetic counseling who are never
addressed so being able to be selective
or personalize the whole personalized
medicine you know how do we do that to
be able to do it this way maybe
prototype for others as well so we don't
see this just a briskets we're not
trying to sell anybody anything to - so
so I have two questions and that first
ones related to it been said and I also
really like the way that you guys kept
track of how many people were how many
women were engaged in that process and
where exactly you lost them at and then
kind of refined along that process of
like realizing oh yeah we're losing
people with this very long informed
consent document we need to revise that
I think that's great
um so similarly do you have any data on
how many people you are able to engage
who wouldn't otherwise get screen or
wouldn't otherwise have access to shared
decision-making tool or wouldn't be
discussing it with their doctor we do
have a little bit of information and
that's just come in recently we we found
that and I thought it was going to be
higher than that of the 118 that we had
only about 60% we're regularly getting
mammograms and that's particularly
important for the 50 to 74 year-olds
where it's recommended it's it's it's
more it's less of an issue for the 40 to
49 year olds but the I was expecting the
the screening rate was gonna be more
like 70 percent but I don't know maybe
you can speak this way below the HEDIS
measure which surprised me we know that
the people engaging our self selecting
and so we need to learn more about our
the people who didn't pursue this did
they are they out to date they just
don't really they know they're up to
date they don't need to go through
shared decision-making they just have
their mammogram a year ago whatever and
they didn't bother to open things really
why they didn't engage there may be
people who aren't technical so this
works well in a a waiting room situation
if they come to their appointment in
connection to it there whereas other
people may be comfortable at home it's
just that we don't know yet but we need
to tailor it to all the users not just
the ones that happen to ship up they
seem to be more risky but then by the
time we do all those subgroup analyses
we're getting small cells so don't make
too big of conclusions there but it's
helpful in the pilot to know what to
anticipate in a bigger study I will say
is that we had eight women report
symptoms of those eight the clinic was
aware of seven but not the eighth so we
actually did identify one person who is
currently experiencing symptoms and
that's not a very big pool although we
only had 118 women so we did identify
one woman who needed out some fairly
quickly follow-up
the second question I have is about em I
know from working on that prostate
cancer screening that they're doing some
really exciting work like in the UK on
kind of refining the algorithm and
including a lot more factors in order to
have better specificity and precision
with you know with who they decide to
screen for prostate cancer um and I
realize this doesn't directly right
relate to the topic of your study but as
you were researching background did you
find out anything interesting about kind
of the factors that we should be looking
for including the more complex ones that
may be you know would you know it would
take a 3-hour interview to all of some
of those factors but you know maybe in
the future that we're able to automate
from the EHR to pull out that
information what we were trying to do
this algorithm and Heidi can speak more
to it has been validated it's used as a
referral tool so if in three minutes the
patient can indicate whether they have
any of the major risk factors present
that should quickly that should shorten
that 3-hour interview but again this
tool is really to refer someone for
genetic counseling it's actually not
saying go get a mammogram right and
what's what's difficult we've done years
worth of systematic reviews for the US
Preventive Services Task Force and
others about the value of risk factors
in predicting breast cancer and the
value of different tools and when you
have a fairly common outcome and you
have very common risk factors they're
not helpful more women get breast cancer
don't have any risk factors than those
who do so it's not that helpful
so we need to be really strategic about
what are the real flags for breast
cancer this may differ with other
conditions of course but in this case
it's not that helpful so we shouldn't
waste our time on that right the tool
moves us in the direction of taking the
flags the actionable items and doing
something with that and as research
moves along there may be something else
we add you know we need to be nimble
enough to change
the science takes us there and so
prostate cancer may be different amounts
familiar but again I think they're stuck
with a big problem it's a fairly common
outcome and it has lots of common risk
factors so finding the unique ones is
difficult and are they really predictive
or they just cause a lot of trouble with
again we're screening right do no harm
so it's tricky it's a little different
than some other shared decision-making
tools that are are done for other things
good questions I was really intrigued by
your study of people's understanding of
uncertainty and I was wondering like
what outcome do you use how do you
assess their ability using the graphic
images to assess whether or not they
understood their risk I'm glad you asked
that we did see actually an earlier
study seventy-five women who
participated within rural clinics we
brought in 21 of those women and I think
Lindsay was actually part of the
interviewing process and she made chime
in we showed them various graphics and
we asked them to tell us in your own
words what you see the other thing is
there was a little quiz and what we did
find is that sometimes they would you
know with the pictographs they might if
the denominators changed which is it's
actually a pretty current common finding
they might confuse the probabilities a
little bit so we had to be pretty
careful with how we presented things but
we did we tried to get capture whether
they understood what they were seeing
through these interviews and I don't
know Lindsay if you want to add anything
more from because Lindsay actually got
to do a lot of those interviews so and
and so the other thing we've used is we
use talk aloud you know when they go
through and they use the tool we'll say
again you clicked on that tell us you
know what why you're clicking on that
and so that also was was revealing as
well people also perceive risk very
differently so you can show somebody and
I think that had play
into what Heidi said about the
scale-model you know some some people
perceive that anytime there's a number
greater than zero oh I'm at risk well
that actually isn't that isn't always
true it often isn't true so you know if
the risk is one out of a thousand some
people react well that's a very small
risk so that's I'm not going to worry
about that someone else might say oh my
gosh it's one out of a thousand I'm I'm
I'm horribly at risk well maybe no if
the average risk is four out of a
thousand so we have to be very careful
in how we word things using plain
language and asking a lot of questions
about what they see I think I think Joan
is up thank you all
[Applause]
thanks Lynn can you hear me so this is a
really good follow-up to the prior
presentation because we're thinking
about a really nice new tool and Ben's
question was very appropriate you have a
great new innovation a new idea how do
you get it used how do you know if it's
going to be used in the right way so I
decided today instead of just telling
you about the present project on medical
scribes I would give you some background
about unintended consequences of health
information technology and how we might
analyze and think I had about how to get
these tools used so about the unintended
consequences of health information
technology
and where's Keeton all right so Keaton
Whitaker is the intern working on the
scribe project and I'll warn him I'll
give him a few minutes at the end to
tell everyone what piece of this is
yours for the summer because I'm going
to be covering 20 years of research and
I'll get to the point where Heaton's
project comes in but I won't spend too
much time on it so this is diffusion of
innovations theory it goes back to
marketing I first heard about it when I
was getting my MBA Everett Rogers wrote
this book way back in 1985 called
diffusion of innovations and since then
at least 6,000 studies have been done
showing that this is a useful theory so
it's one of those very general fabulous
theories that you all need to know about
and I recommend the book basically in a
nutshell diffusion of innovations is the
process by which an innovation or
anything new new idea and IT tool is
communicated through certain channels
over time among members of a social
system and
every single underlying thing here has
been studied to death but this is my
little picture of it because I want to
show you what leads up to unintended
consequences and so we have a you know
wonderful new informatics tool which is
the innovation and we're hoping it gets
adopted maybe glacially but adopted over
time and we can help things along with
promotion with communication with
advertising and there are consequences
once it's adopted and so everyone
thought that EHRs would do nothing but
good in the world right and the
consequences would be better health care
for all nobody thought that there might
be unintended consequences of EHRs or
health information technology but when
you look at it this way what happens is
there are unintended consequences and we
try to solve the problems caused by the
original tool so the original tool might
have been EHRs the under 10 the
consequence is providers aren't
necessarily happy with every part of the
EHR that's the unintended consequence
and so then we try to make things better
and communication was being decreased
because of information technology and
hospitals right and so nurses started
using both Cera which is a communication
tool you hang around your neck just like
this and that that was a new unintended
consequence brand new invention to make
up for the old invention of EHRs EHRs
decreased communication both Cera comes
in it's it's really good for sales of
new innovations when this happens but
it's almost a spiral we get something
happening and then we try to solve the
problem so that's just what's happened
with medical scribes what we're on going
from here so unintended consequences are
defined as
events are reactions arising from the
introduction of a new innovation or
technology or process not part of the
intended purpose or goal and the little
cartoon here shows this poor man trying
to wrest this elbow and all the Domino's
are going to fall until one of them
falls on top of him unintended quonset
consequences if it's on purpose
then it's not unattended right so the
other word for an unattended
consequences of the surprise so in 2004
the notion of unintended consequences
was novel
maybe it wasn't novel but it was not
being discussed because it was creepy it
was not something we and informatics
wanted to let anybody know because we
wanted everyone to think health
information technology was going to you
know be wonderful for healthcare but I
had been studying inflammation of CPOE
and two of my colleagues around the
world one in the Netherlands the other
in Australia were studying
implementation of CPOE in their
countries using we were all using
similar ethnographic techniques and we
happened to be at a conference together
in Heidelberg Germany and we started
talking about these creepy things that
were happening like mistakes being made
because of health information technology
that never would have been made in the
paper world and so we got together and
when he wrote this paper and this was
way back in 2004 and believe me it was
considered revolutionary and it
surprises me two days ago I looked at
jami'a and saw that it's the most cited
paper in the history of jami'a now and
it goes all the way back to 2004 so
funny thing we're still interested in
unintended consequences of health
information technology so I'll go over
the last twenty years of research which
we've my colleague Dean sitting and I
have published in this really pretty
book Lemon's lemon-aid being made out of
lemons that's
our idea of unintended consequences
we've done a whole bunch of site visits
this whole series of studies about
provider order entry unintended
consequences decision support and the
unintended consequences of that health
information technology risk of H ite and
finally scribes as an unintended
consequence of a chai tea so we learned
so much going into the field looking for
unintended consequences and it was
interesting to me that people actually
invited us to come and look but they
wanted to learn too
the risk factors and and what was going
on within their own organisations so we
did find that there can be unexpected
positive unintended consequences and
this is this is a good one he turns the
patient instructions on the screen to
the patient and they go over it line by
line clarifying any questions and the
patient finds an error and this happens
we've seen it happen everywhere when
patients are engaged providers if they
know what they're doing are often
turning the screen to the patients and
including them in the conversation and
the patient sometimes sees something
that's fabulous and that was not
expected but there can be negative or
adverse unintended consequences which
are the interesting ones there they're
the Oates's they're the mistakes and
this is an example of a wrong dose quote
you just have to double-check you know
that's what you're supposed to do but I
know people get fast and that's when
errors are made and so maybe someone
really would prescribe these pills to an
infant these are actually pills for
horses but we do know that medication
errors can be made
just because you click the wrong thing
on a drop-down menu this couldn't have
happened in the paper world there can
also be two-sided consequences where
they could be good or bad
they could be good for one person they
could be bad for someone else or like
this example someone said I'm glad the
computer goes down sometimes otherwise
I'd forget how to use paper now this is
a very you know upbeat optimistic
tolerant person but sometimes there are
two sides to an unintended consequence
so our team going in and doing all these
sightless that's found 380 examples of
unintended consequences and we
categorize them really really carefully
we came up with came up with these nine
types we've written papers about all of
them so you can go back and look at the
publication's if you're interested in
any particular one but I'm gonna focus
on the new kinds of errors because
everyone else likes to focus on those
two the Ease are insidious silent errors
very often juxtaposition errors we use
that term to describe these errors that
can be made when you use a drop-down
menu and something is just really close
to something else and you click on it
quote I ordered the test that was right
next to the one I thought I ordered you
know right below it my little thingy or
the cursor had come down and I clicked
and I'm looking at this one but in fact
I clicked on the thing before it by that
time I turned my head I'm hitting return
and typing my signature and not seeing
it and this was a quote when we go in
and we observe this was a quote someone
a provider gave us by turning around
saying see I just made a mistake you
know they always complain to us but we
actually saw this happening how often do
you think it happens without someone
knowing about it
this person figured it out and told us
about it but very very often it's very
common that they enter the wrong order
hopefully the pharmacist catches it or
their nurse catch it soon here's an
interesting unintended consequence a
colleague of mine in Great Britain sent
it it's from the time
and it's another prescribing error but
it's not a dosage error like the one we
were talking about before in this
particular outpatient system every time
I provide or ordered viagra I'm sorry
every time they ordered this zyban drug
for smoking cessation the system somehow
translated that into viagra and so all
these smoking people were getting viagra
when they went to the pharmacy and
there's cute little cartoon that says
I've given up smoking but now I'm on a
packet of condoms a day and way down at
the bottom you can't see it says no one
was harmed by this so this happens so
now how are scribes and unintended
consequence of a chai tea first I need
to tell you who scribes are on this
research is funded by arc Jeff Gould is
the principal investigator Vishnu is
another principal investigator on this
as am i so this is one of those
two-sided unintended consequences
because sometimes it's positive
sometimes it's negative it became an
industry because providers were forced
to use the EHR remember my circular
diagram they had to use the EHR they
became overburdened they're getting
burned out from so many things the EHR
is enabling that burn out and so they
needed help and they cried for help and
a new industry came forward to save the
day the upside being this new industry
gives jobs to usually young people right
out of college who want to be accepted
into a professional school like nursing
school PA school or a medical school so
they get a job in the past often they
just volunteered a shadow right in a
clinical setting to learn something
about it and to put on their CV for
medical school now they can actually get
a paid job to do it so they get
something out of this very positive the
providers get something out of it
help at the elbow by really bright
people however and this is why arc
funded us there was a suspicion that
there might be some safety issues here
because scribes have no license shirt
and no clinical training and they're
entering orders and they're doing things
for providers that do carry some risk so
what is a scribe
someone who uses the EHR to provide
documentation assistance to providers
there's no specific licensure for
scribes CMS DMV there are guidelines
that they give the Joint Commission
offers some guidance but they say they
need the support nor prohibit the use of
scribes so it's it's a new profession
Emmys were in the same position a number
of years ago and I first started
visiting hospitals amazed had no
particular licensure either it was very
variable how much training they had had
now it's the same thing with scribes
they can be right out of college and not
have late don't don't even have to have
graduated from colleges and some in some
places so there's no licensure for them
so our study purpose was to make
scribing safer to describe the
activities of scribes who use the EHR so
that we could learn best practices to
turn those best practice ideas into
competencies which is where Keaton comes
in and those competencies will then be
translated into training modules that
arc will make available freely
nationally and internationally and
that's the five-year plan for our
project so we used this model as a
framework for studying scribes to make
sure that we cover all of these things
the personal environmental technical and
organizational perspectives and we used
our rapid ethnography technique where we
go on-site because so little had been
known well first about CPOE provider
order entry when nothing is known
it's really helpful for somebody to
paint a picture of what's going on now
and that's what we do with our
ethnography so we're painting this broad
picture of what scribing is like across
the country right now we use a team to
go in and do this and we do it fairly
expeditiously we use a multidisciplinary
team several different techniques for
this study it's primarily interviews and
observations and we employ what we call
a grounded hermeneutic approach to
analysis meaning just that we take the
words of those in the field and we
analyze them to come up with conclusions
so you don't have to read this I just
want to give you the impression that we
did collect a lot of data we went to
five different sites around the country
very carefully selected we did over 80
interviews many many observations in the
field so just to summarize from the
patient perspective so this is from the
personal perspective that I told you
about the patient's perspective told us
that they appreciate having the provider
pay attention to them we all have had
the feeling when we are in the doctors
off of a exam room and the providers
just typing and they're not looking at
us and they're paying more attention to
the computer than they are to us it's
pretty irksome this way you can have a
scribe unobtrusively in the background
and the provider can pay attention to
you they like that and they rarely
object to having a scribe in the room
the challenges to this are providers
very often don't tell the patient what
that person is doing in the room which
is a little you know disconcerting for
the patient so proper introductions
should always be made these are this is
one of the best practices we found often
as not being done because patients can
be puzzled and some of them may feel
uncomfortable and not say so
many of the people we interviewed who
were not patients by the way we did not
talk directly to patients we talked to
managers to scribes and to providers and
we asked them how patients thought so we
didn't talk to the patient's directly
the others told us that some of the
Press Ganey scores which is you've all
been asked for these after you've seen
the doctor have been in the hospital you
have to rate your experience and some
people have written some comments saying
they feel a little uncomfortable under
some circumstances having the extra
person in the room this is not not
common though mostly they like having
the doctor pay attention to them from
the scribe personal perspective it's
great that kick-starts your career you
can get a recommendation for medical
school you can actually get paid for
something that's pretty fun to do you're
constantly learning and you're making a
contribution to healthcare the challenge
is they get minimum wage usually and
they're worth way more and they know it
so that arcs them in this pre
professional model where they don't stay
very long because very often they do get
accepted to school and they're no longer
scribes there's a lot of turnover here
there is a more professional model of
scribing where you have a medical
assistant or a nurse do scribing but
primarily we're looking at this pre
professional model because it's more
common and the scribes told us the
providers vary in style this is a nice
way of saying you get some cranky
providers that you're working with once
in a while and they may do things that
make you uncomfortable or they may not
introduce you and that kind of thing
some scribes may have held back and what
they told us because after all they're
they've been hired and they work for
companies and sometimes the companies
have non-disclosure agreements and found
all different reasons for scribes maybe
not being as open as they could have
been but we still got an earful so from
the organizational perspective now they
feel documentation is better so we went
in thinking maybe documentation
it's worth having untrained people doing
it these people do it all day long they
know the EHR and you know I'd say 98% of
the people we talk to feel that
documentation is a lot better having a
scribe do it standardization can be done
this way because you have the scribe
used templates and most places keep on
top of how well the scribe is doing the
documentation maybe even more so than
they did for providers and we saw so
many times when scribes really really
help the provider and say well don't
forget you told mrs. so-and-so that you
were going to order this and prices oh
yeah you know having that third person
in the room actually can be really
helpful the challenge is the scribe has
to see or be told something that was
done so the provider has to talk during
an exam for example to make sure that
the scribe can't caught everything some
providers it's hard for them to do that
on the provider often does not review
the work very carefully once they learn
to trust a scribe they let the scribe go
with it but it's their responsibility
it's so much their responsibility they
really should be looking at the
documentation carefully workflow
efficiency organizations felt really did
improve the only issues were a brand new
scribe was ah you know obviously going
to be a little slower than a scribe that
has at least six months worth of
experience but mostly really helps the
workflow for an environmental
perspective the scribe industry has
emerged so this is you know this is good
for the companies who hire out the
scribes this is good for the scribes
it's good for organizations that don't
want to go through the you huge Human
Resources impacts of constant turnover
with scribes so the challenge is there's
minimal regulation big big industry
hugely growing industry little
standardization so we really do need to
do something about this we did not study
this overseas model where this ad says
become a virtual doctor in six weeks by
becoming a scribe a remote scribe might
be some safety issues there also from
the environmental perspective compliance
safety risks there is some guidance
available that challenges our there
needs to be a whole lot more guidance
available the EHR has issues everyone in
this room knows that scribes are usually
really good at it because they they use
the EHR all day long they go through the
training and we found I think this is so
beautiful very often they're super users
after all they're right there in the
middle of things and other providers
other health care professionals can
count on them for knowing the EHR so
sometimes their official epic super
users for for example however they need
continuous training and sometimes they
work for a scribe company they don't
even work for the organization they're
working in they may not get the constant
updates you may might get on epic for
example and ergonomics there there are
always issues with aergon omics because
the rooms were not designed to have that
extra third person in them so to
summarize what we found out in the field
there are upsides and there are
downsides and risks and we had not even
thought to focus on the provider and
training that might be needed for the
provider we thought all the risks were
because we had untrained scribes out
there but it turns out it's the
providers responsibility to make sure
the scribe is doing what they're
supposed to be doing and the providers
have usually no clue about the best
practices we're using a scribe so we
will be recommending that providers get
training as well as
yet further training we are going to be
developing the further training we held
at the end of all of these site visits a
conference of 30 experts from around the
country we met for two days we got so
much good information from that group
about the competencies we had found that
are needed in all scribes and the
competencies the experts from around the
country feel all scribes need and I'm
gonna let heat and talk now about the
next steps because we have umpteen pages
of transcripts from these two days worth
of discussions and let's see lenka Zhu
Han Keaton the microphone yeah as Joan
mentioned we're working to develop these
competencies from the interview and and
record data that they collected from the
conference so to create these
competencies they've divided them into
two lists there's general scribe
competencies that ascribe just needs to
work in a doctor's office in an exam
room and then there's EHR related
competencies that directly relate to the
work that they do with the EHR so the
study that I'm hoping to conduct is a
modified Delphi study which is kind of
casting into the future and seeing what
and scribes will be able to and will
need to be able to do so that they can
develop modules to help train scribes in
the future so this first round is
developing lists of competencies that
are definitely necessary for both
general competencies and EHR
competencies and then eventually we'll
move on to ranking these competencies so
we can really hone in on what's going to
be important for scribes to know from
the perspective of providers scribe
managers Hospital is hospital
administration and those kind of people
great summary thank you so much and yeah
so it's a partnership between the
scribes and the providers that's the
bottom line so maybe we'll get another
grant after this one for competencies
for provide
using scribes so we have maybe two
minutes for questions sorry about that
dr. ash how does that jive with dr.
Mayan Gold's study in the simulation lab
where the experienced scribes that were
in one department for a long time their
accuracy and their interval is all over
the map between 30 and 80 percent that's
proof that the scribes need more
training we need some really good data
from actual documentation we heard that
everyone's happy with the scribes but we
don't have that really data-driven
result to show that what people are
feeling is actually happening in the
field so we need more of that kind of
thing and dr. Gould definitely knows
that on the results he iment on the
results you mentioned that
administrators were more happy with the
completeness of the documentation was
there any validation of that that that
was accurate valid completeness as
opposed to things in templates keeping
their default that are checking off
boxes for billing but may or may not be
clinically accurate or appropriate it's
really interesting that these scribe
companies and I have to say I went into
the study thinking the scribe companies
may be a little on the sleazy side on
the other hand we have learned that
these scribe companies are really on top
of things and the three different ones
we studied every single month they get a
report from providers so they have to
make you happy another reason for your
going over the documentation so that you
can say and that forces them to so that
you can say yes my scribe did a great
job in documentation this month
so you say that part of it that health
information management people and the
billing people look usually they do I
should have mentioned audits I think I
had them on one of my slides that
usually there's a monthly audit of what
the scribe is doing so they there is
oversight when these organizations are
doing it the way they should be doing it
there are many small organizations that
just hire scribes off the street trained
them themselves they don't like the EHR
so they decide to have a scribe come and
use the EHR and so they may not be the
best people to do the training but there
are many places that do that they don't
have audits they don't have you know the
provider really doesn't oversee very
well we'll have to include that in our
provider training is the importance of
monitoring really really carefully so I
I have trust
so I know we have a model for
simulations with gotchas and cases - for
instance train residents or nurses about
common EHR navigation errors that can be
patient safety issues have they built
scribe cases where they're specifically
trying to have gotchas for providers in
terms of